[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAN SANDLER: Hi.
My name is Dan.
I'm here with Hyunyoung
and Sunny and Selim.
And we are from the Android
system UI and launcher teams.
We always have some fun
stuff in every release.
We're going to talk
about some of it here.
Some of it's great stuff
for users, some of it's
stuff you need to
know as developers.
Either way, we're
really proud of it.
These are the people
that built it.
I'm super proud to be up here
with them telling you about it.
So let's-- we got a
lot to talk about.
I don't want to
waste a lot of time.
Hyunyoung, why don't
you take it away?
Tell us about new
stuff in icons.
HYUNYOUNG SONG:
OK, thank you Dan.
Hi, everybody.
My name is Hyunyoung
Song, and today I'm
going to talk about
new changes that we
introduced around launcher
icons in O platform.
OK, so what is the problem that
we're trying to solve here?
One of the things the developers
like about pre-O Android icons
is that it's very flexible.
Aside from the constraint that
Play Console impose on you,
the 48 dp size limit, you
can choose whatever shape
or size or padding or
shadow that you like.
Of course, there's a
material UI design guideline
around how you should do
them, but not all developers
abides by them.
And so this flex--
and this flexibility is
actually a double edged sword
because, if you look at a lot
of the OEM launcher screens
or home screens,
what you notice is
that your icon doesn't look
the same as what you actually
added to your APK.
Like in this example of
Chrome and Play Store icon,
they shrink it
down, and then they
put it on a background
color that the OEM decided.
In this example, the
same Play Store icon
is cut around the corners.
And at least these icons
preserve its original look.
Sometimes they even
use icon packs,
which completely changes how
your brand identity looks like.
And that's what we're trying
to solve in Adaptive Icons.
So let's bring up
the slides that you
may have seen Dan
already presented
during What's New in Android O.
So there's a simple formula--
app developers will provide
foreground and background
layers.
One of these layers have
to be full-bleed, opaque.
And the different devices--
the OEM or the platform, they
specify what kind of mask that
will be used on these icons.
If the mask was
circle, then the user
will see circle-shaped icons all
across the system UI surfaces.
And this not only
include the launcher,
but settings UI, apps
list, apps info page,
and then also the recents
and overview titlebar.
And lastly the
share sheet dialog
will also use this
launcher icon.
So the shape will change
throughout these surfaces.
If the mask was
rounded direct then
the result will be
a round direct icon.
So while we were
changing the Android--
the icon API, the first
thing that we also changed
is the visible size of the icon.
Previously, it used to be 48 dp.
But lately, there are
wider range of icon sizes
that different launchers,
third party launchers uses.
And some of them are 60
dp, some of them are 72 dp.
So we decided that the
visible size should be 72 dp.
But the foreground
and background layer
that we actually want
you to upgrade to,
we want you to provide 108 dp.
We want you to add 25%
of the viewport inset
around four edges, either
using the extension
of your foreground layer,
or as a transparency
so that we can add delightful
animations such these,
like the parallax, and
pulsing, and there is actually
a lot more.
But unfortunately, on your
today's developer preview,
you will not see any
of these animations
because we're still vetting
how to best place these.
But it will come up
in future releases.
So let's talk about safe zone.
When you're adding your main
logo, or the badge of your icon
in the foreground layer,
you might be curious, OK,
how do I make sure
that all of these
show up on every
single platform?
And that's what safe
zone does for you.
When an OEM defines
their mask shape,
it cannot cut into
the safe zone.
And this is enforced
by the system--
by the API.
What this means is
that if you happen
to have a badge on the
right bottom corner
of this risky zone that I
labeled, then what it will mean
is that if it's rendered
on a platform that
is close to a rectangle,
then it may get shown.
But if it's on a device where
it has circle mask shape,
it'll be clipped off,
or not shown at all.
But I'm not saying that
you should not add badges.
Just make sure that they're
inside the safe zone
to be shown on every platform.
OK, so let's talk about API.
The main class that
we added to O platform
is AdaptiveIconDrawable class.
It supports two elements--
background and foreground,
and one attribute-- drawable,
where you can specify either
the asset or another--
basically you can specify
either a drawable or a color.
And where this class fits
in the drawable family tree,
its parent probably could
be the LayerDrawable,
and its half sibling will
be the RippleDrawable.
And after you define
this XML file,
you don't actually specify
this in Android manifest file.
The old Android icon
attribute is still in affect.
As a matter of fact, you do
not remove the Legacy icon
because in previous platforms
before O, they will not--
it will not know how to handle
or inflate adaptive icons.
So you still have to
keep this adaptive icon.
But as of O, what
you do is, you'd
create a same-name XML file
as the Legacy png asset,
and then add it
into mipmap-anydpi.
And whatever foreground and
background layer is neat,
like this ic_foreground.png,
you'd add it
to the density-specific
mipmap directory.
And at compile time, AAPT will
scan your mipmap and your DPI
directory.
And if it sees
adaptive icon, it'll
move to v26 particular
directory so
that only platform 26 and above
will inflate it and use it.
One thing to note is that some
of you good Android citizen may
already know about
this round icon
attribute that we added in NMR1.
If you happen to be the few
Android developers that did use
it, then we recommend that you
create the same-name XML file
as the Legacy--
as the original adaptive
icon file, but the contents
can be the same.
Now, regarding why we decided
to not deprecate this,
and why you have
to override this,
I am not going to
go into detail,
but I strongly urge you to
read them on our websites.
Now, some of you
sitting in the audience
may think 108 dp,
that is really huge.
And maybe to make
the matter worse,
your APK size is very close to
hitting that Play Console max
size limit.
In which case,
what you can do is,
in O, we added fraction-type.
The inset drawables
support fraction-type.
And if you remember, the
inset that I asked you to add
was 18 dp.
If you divide that
by 108, that is 16%.
So if you specify
16% as your inset,
and then use your Legacy--
appoint the inset drawables'
main content to be
the Legacy icon,
then there will be
no APK size increase,
and you will be able to upgrade
to adaptive icons for free.
And, as of Android N,
the vector drawables
became so much more expressive
that almost every element
in SVG file can now be
supported in vector drawables.
So if you actually
use vector drawables
as either your foreground
and background element,
then your APK size
will actually decrease.
And now I'm going to do a demo
of how the icon wizard now
support creating
adaptive icon wizard.
If you right click your
resource directory,
and then choose New Image
Asset, then you get this page.
And here you can
configure your foreground,
you can select different
asset type as image.
I'm going to choose Image here.
And then, what you're
seeing on the right side is,
this is a preview of
what your icon will
look like on four different
platforms with different mask.
And what you're
adding into your APK
is actually presented
here in full-bleed layers.
Now, you can toggle
the show safe zone
to see if your foreground
element is fully
within the safe zone.
And so that you can
resize, you make
sure that everything
is the foreground.
And in background
layer, I'm going
to change the color to
something hopefully help--
not so help, OK, whatever.
And then that's what
we're going to use.
And the last tab is
actually very important
because as I mentioned earlier,
if you just add adaptive icons,
your app will not have any
icons in previous platforms.
So you can use this third
tab to generate the Legacy
icon, the Legacy round icon
for circle shape mask shaped
devices.
And then this--
you can also even
generate the 512 by 512
image that you upload
to your Play Console here.
And then click Next.
And then, this is the
same directory structure
that I showed you earlier on.
You'll say Finish.
And then since-- before all
devices become available,
you can test this
on the emulator.
And now I'm installing the app.
And as you can see, this is
the icon that I just created.
And this emulator has
circle as the mask.
And-- oh, OK.
Oh.
And so what I'm showing
you right now is,
this is an option that you
can see on the main launcher
of your emulator.
It lets you-- first, this
is what it should have been.
The main mask shape on
this device is circle.
But just for
developer purpose, you
can change the icon
shape so that you
can check what it will
look like on other devices.
And let's pick something
fun, like teardrop.
And so now you have
teardrop shape icon
without having to
make any changes.
[APPLAUSE]
That's all, everything
to adaptive icons.
And on that note,
I'll pass it off
to Sunny, who will tell you more
about shortcuts and widgets.
SUNNY GOYAL: Thank you, HY.
[APPLAUSE]
Hello, everyone.
Just now, Hyunyoung
Song talked about how
to make your app icons
look even better.
This helps a lot in improving
your app's experience.
Another way to improve
your app's experience
is by adding shortcuts.
Shortcuts allow apps to
expose deep links directly
on the user's home screen.
For example, a
messenger app can expose
shortcut for frequently
used contacts,
allowing the user to get
to those contacts quickly.
An app can define
a shortcut using
API defined last year in NML1.
It would give it a
shortcutting for object,
and parsing all the
related information,
like label, icon, and intent.
Then using the
ShortcutManager manager class,
it can add, update, or
delete the shortcuts.
The system will manage
the shortcuts for the app,
and even back them up
on the cloud if needed.
These dynamically-added
shortcuts
are shown as additional
options for the app.
For example, when Hyunyoung
clicked that icon.
but the launcher can
also allow the user
to pin the shortcuts
on the home screen
where they exist as
independent icons.
Previously, to create
these pin shortcuts,
an app would send a
install shortcut broadcast,
and hope that the
launcher gets to broadcast
and does the right thing.
But there are many
downsides to this flow.
For example, the
app loses control,
and there's no way
for the app to know
that the shortcut was added.
Also, since the user is
not involved in this flow,
there's a potential for spam.
Starting with Android O,
this API will no longer work.
Instead, the app would
get a ShortcutInfo object,
as explained in previous
slides, and call
the requestPinShortcut API.
This will make the launcher
show a confirmation prompt,
allowing the user
to pin the shortcut,
place the shortcut
on the home screen.
Once a shortcut is
added, it behaves
like any other shortcut,
and can be updated
using the existing APIs.
Another way to create
shortcut is from the registry.
An app can define
a custom shortcut
which shows a configuration
activity when the user tries
to add them on the home screen.
To define a custom
shortcut, the app
would declare the
configuration activity
in the manifest with the
create shortcut intent filter.
This is the activity which
is started before the app--
before the user adds the
shortcut on the home screen,
which allows the user to
configure the shortcut.
From this activity,
the app would
return the shortcut
as Intent.EXTRA
directly to the launcher.
This has similar downsides as
the INSTALL_SHORTCUT flow--
that the app loses control, and
it does not work cross-profile.
In O, now app can directly
return a shortcut info object,
and thus retain control
over the shortcut.
From the registry, a user
can also add widgets.
Now, this is the only way
for a user to add widget.
If an app wants to
add a widget, it
will have to explain
to the user how
to get to the registry, which
may vary from device to device.
Now, in O, an app can simply
call the RequestPinAppWidget
a API This will show
a confirmation prompt
similar to that of a shortcut,
and allow user to place
the widget on the home screen.
Once the widget has
been added, the app
would get the widget ID
as part of the callback,
and can be used to
update the widget.
To summarize the changes,
INSTALL_SHORTCUT broadcast
will no longer work on O.
Doesn't matter if the app is
targeting O or not.
An app should instead
use the new APIs
to add shortcuts and widget.
Make sure to check out
the documentation for more
information on these APIs.
[APPLAUSE]
I'll hand over to Selim
for notifications.
SELIM CINEK: Thank you, Sunny.
Hello, everyone.
I'm Selim, and I'm here today
to talk about notifications.
Notifications have been one of
the key components of Android
for many years.
And in each of our
previous releases,
we have continuously
improved on them.
In Android O, we are
further improving our system
in many different areas.
Let me first talk about the
visual changes we are doing.
The first key area of
improvements that we are doing
is the channel visual
notification hierarchy.
For a user, not
all notifications
are created alike.
So for example, a
user cares way more
about the messaging notification
compared to a lower party
weather notification.
But in today's world,
all notifications
look very similar, and the
user has a really hard time
parsing its notifications.
So starting in
Android O, we're going
to be more opinionated about
the order of notifications.
In order to do this, we're
dividing the section up
in four different areas.
On the very top, we have a new
section called Major Ongoing.
Below these, we have People
to People notifications,
followed tightly by General
notifications that behave
just the way they do today.
On the very bottom, we also
have a new section called
By The Way notifications.
Let me go into detail for
all of these sections.
So the very first section
that appears on the very top
is called the Major
Ongoing, and it
is reserved for high
priority ongoing tasks.
Good examples here are
music notifications,
like an ongoing
navigation notification,
or basically only
something that is
really important to
the user, and the user
must know that it exists.
There are basically two ways
how a notification can end up
in this area.
The first one doesn't require
any developer interaction
at all.
And this reserved for
media notifications.
Starting in Android
O, we are going
to colorize the background
of notifications
based on the media artwork.
An example you can
see on the slide--
as you can see, we are
extracting the background
and the foreground
color directly
from the album
artwork, and it will
creates a really nice,
structured image.
The second way how a
notification can be colorized
is by opting in
by the developer.
So a developer actually
has to do something
if he wants to get there.
The way to do this is, it's
reserve for foreground services
notifications.
And they can use a
new method called
setColorized on the builder.
The background
color will then be
colorized by the app-provided
notification color.
I want to really stress here
that please, please, please
don't abuse these [INAUDIBLE].
We're putting a lot
of, lot of trust
into the developer ecosystem.
And if you see just
being abused too much,
we will have to change
it in the future.
Another thing I really want
to stress that's colorized
isn't the new white.
By default, a notification
shouldn't be colorized.
We don't want to create a
shade of rainbow colors.
We want to achieve the opposite.
We want to put focus on the
one notification that matters.
All right, so below these
ongoing notification,
we have People to
People notifications.
And research has shown
that users usually
care about people
notification the most.
And if you're
interested about that,
you should definitely go
to this talk tomorrow.
It's happening at 12:30,
and it's a design talk.
And [INAUDIBLE] if you're
interested about how
to post notifications,
and how developers today
abuse all our notification,
you should really go there.
So in Android O, we're
transforming People
to People notifications
by, first of all,
ranking them higher up so
that the user sees them
more quickly.
And second of all, we're
also expanding their size.
So even in a collapsed
form, the user
can see up to three
lines of text,
which obviously makes it way
easier to parse a notification.
And this also happens
on a lock screen.
So if you have been away from
your phone and come back,
you can immediately see what is
relevant, and get back to it.
All right, so below
these People to People
notifications, as I said, are
the channel notifications.
They behave just like
they did before, and--
so I won't go into
detail to that section.
So the last section in
the notification chain
is called By The
Way notification.
And this is completely new.
And as you can
see, in Android O,
we are transforming these
min priority notifications
to show only a
single line of text.
A user, if he's
interested in it,
he can still make that
visible by clicking on it.
Good examples of
notifications that
should appear there
are an ongoing traffic
notification, the weather--
basically anything that
is important and could
actually relevant, but doesn't
require immediate attention.
All right, so this completes the
visual notification hierarchy.
And let's get to the next
feature we are working on.
So the other feature
we working on
is called the Visual Stability.
And let's consider a situation
you maybe encounter every day.
You're carefully
crafting, and you
reply to maybe a friend, Selim.
And just about when
you were to hit send,
then obviously the whole
notification just going
to reorder.
And it sucks, and probably you
hit the wrong notification,
and magic stuff happens, and
you don't know what happened.
And of course, this is
a really bad experience,
and we want to improve on it.
And so the goal sounds
relatively simple--
don't reorder notifications
while you're looking at them.
In reality, unfortunately,
this is slightly harder
than it sounds because if you
get a new message, for example,
you still want to know
about that, right?
And yeah.
We actually like
this feature so much
that it's even
available in NMR2,
and we backboarded it there.
So if you have a phone already
in NMR2, that's already there.
All right, so if you know me,
and you know me personally,
I'm all about notifications.
And I'm all about animations
with notification.
I care about every detail, and
even the slightest little thing
should be pixel
perfect and animated.
And in Android O, my
designers and my coworkers
let me off my
leash a little bit,
and I was allowed to go wild.
So I created this animation
between expand, and basically
where we expand the
notification chain.
I think the slide explains it
way better than I ever could,
but the key goal,
essentially, is
to create a sense of
object permanence.
A user should always know
where his notification are,
no matter whether
they're collapsed
in an icon form
in the status bar,
or when they're expanded
into full modification shade.
And obviously there needs to
be a really nice transition
between those.
As you can see, By
The Way notification
appear on the very bottom,
and appear as overflow dots
to indicate an overflow.
And they go away when
you close the shade.
All right, let me
hand it over to Dan
to talk about channels
and other nice features.
[APPLAUSE]
DAN SANDLER: Thanks, Selim.
HYUNYOUNG SONG: Nice job.
DAN SANDLER: Hi, it's me again.
Notification
channels is probably
the biggest piece of new API
surface in the notification
system.
So there's a lot of interesting
design decisions there.
Let's talk about it.
OK, so let's just start
with the base assumption
that apps post a lot
of notifications.
Like, kind of a lot.
But that's OK, because
users like notifications,
also kind of a lot.
So there's actually a
good state of affairs.
And to tell you the
full story of channels,
I need to sort of stop for a
second and talk about my friend
here.
It might be your friend.
This is my friend.
This is the
neurotransmitter dopamine.
It's actually a cartoon of
the neurotransmitter dopamine,
which is fine, because
I'm not a neuroscientist,
so you shouldn't
really trust anything
I say about brain
chemistry anyway.
But let's just say
that this is dopamine.
It's really, really complicated
how it works in the brain,
in the body.
It's involved in
all kinds of stuff.
But what we're going
to talk about today
is the things that
it's associated
with that I show here.
So things like
anticipation of reward,
motivation seeking rewards,
your attention, salience,
you're in the moment and
looking for something--
including the right
word for that slide.
It's basically the user
engagement chemical
in your brain.
And so bringing
this back to what
we were talking about
here, dopamine on its own
doesn't make you happy, right?
There are lots of other great
neurotransmitters and chemicals
that make you feel
happy and satisfied.
That's not it's purpose.
Dopamine is to get you there.
And notifications work
exactly the same way.
They get your attention,
you become attuned to them,
you anticipate a reward,
so you tap on it.
Maybe what's behind
it is useful, maybe
what's behind it is
deeply satisfying.
You hope it is, maybe it's not.
So with every app fighting for
the user's limited attention
span, limited supply of
dopamine, limited ability
to care about
distractions and stuff
that the device wants
to tell you, suddenly
you're not nearly as excited
about those notifications
at all.
And everybody loses.
The user loses,
every app loses, it's
a tragedy of the commons
in a classic sense.
But I know that's actually not
a problem for anybody in here.
All of you-- I can tell
just by looking at you,
you've all got
good notifications.
Your notifications are the
ones that the user really
wants to see.
I know that.
I understand.
We get ourselves.
But there are other
notifications out there that
are not doing so well, right?
So maybe you messed
up one time, and you
made a notification that had
a really loud beeping tone,
and so the user banned
your app forever.
Or like when you had a
new recommendation engine,
and your machine learning was
kind of in machine preschool,
and it didn't recommend
the right thing,
so the user blocked your
app or uninstalled it.
Or you're trying to try out
some new kind of notification
that you know that some of
your users are going to love,
and others are
going to like, yeah,
I could take it or leave it.
And you're running the risk
of making them unhappy.
So the Android way is to
give users control, OK?
And Android already lets you
have a little bit of control
over apps that are maybe
not quite matched to what
you expect other notifications.
You can uninstall them.
In Jellybean, we added
the ability for you
to block notifications, but
leave the rest of the app
working just as it did.
In Nougat, we made that
a little more refined,
gave you some more options.
But in Android O,
we're introducing
notification channels.
So a channel is a data structure
that you create and hand
to the notification
manager that describes
a category of notifications
from your app specific
to your channel,
specific to your app--
they don't match any
other app's channels.
Everything on the channel
shares the same behavior.
And you see some icons
representing the behavior
there.
Behaviors like sound,
vibration, whether they pop up
on the screen, whether they
light the LED, and so forth.
And this category is
arranged so that the user can
understand these notifications,
and can control them.
Category of
notifications from an app
with the same
behavior so the user
can understand and control them.
All right, I've got an example
here from a fictitious airline
Crane Air.
Usually they post
notifications like,
your flight is delayed,
which are really important.
Or here's your boarding
pass, also extremely useful.
And then one day they post
you something that says,
you earned 2,560 points today.
You're only 500
points away from being
able to sit in the humane seats.
So many users might
really love this.
Oh my gosh, that's fantastic.
Oh, I'll take that last trip.
I'll get to that status level.
Others users might
find, OK, wow,
I'm just going to
uninstall this app,
I don't need that kind
of garbage in my life.
In a channels
world, in Android O,
you can long-press
this notification,
or use our new
short swipe gesture
to get to the inside of this
notification, the Inspector,
where you can see the
app that posted it.
Of course you want
that accountability,
we introduced that in Nougat.
You also see the
name of the channel.
In this case, the channel
is The Executive Program.
You see that there are other
channels available to sort
of give you context.
And of course you see here,
it's called Categories.
Our user-facing name for
this feature is Categories,
but of course, you and
I know that we already
had something inside
the notification
API called Categories.
So internally it's
called Channels,
but we call it Categories
in the UI strings.
So if you really-- you
got this notification,
you long-press, you
see this screen.
What do you do?
You touch that switch
on the right hand side,
and they're gone.
The Executive Program
notifications only are gone.
Every other notification
from that app
works as it did before.
OK, all right, so maybe you
didn't want to block them.
That's useful information,
but it beeped,
it made the phone do something
that you didn't like.
So OK, maybe this is
the kind of notification
that you would prefer to be
more of the By The Way sort
that Selim described.
So instead of
hitting the switch,
you touch All Categories.
All Categories takes you into
the Android Settings app.
This is not setting surface
that you create in your app,
this is actually in
settings.APK on the ROM.
It shows you the app name, it
gives you a big master switch
that you can block
notifications as you always
have been able to do.
It's got a switch that I'll tell
you about the end of the talk,
and then it lists
all the categories.
And each of these corresponds to
one of the notification channel
objects that you
created and handed off
to the notification
manager to partition
your space of notifications.
From this space,
the user can quickly
block or unblock that
channel, and even
dig in deeper to control
the very specific details
of that behavior, if
you really want to.
Because again, the
point here is that we're
giving the user control over
everything the app can do.
Before I move on,
I want to point out
that there is a link
at the bottom there
that goes straight to your
app's own notification settings.
We'll talk in a little
bit about what goes here,
and what goes there.
But just to show you
an example, if you
touch one of those
channels, you'll
see a screen a little bit like
this where you can, again,
block just that channel.
That switch is the
same as the one
you saw in the previous
slide on the row item.
You can change the
importance, which
is our new system that
replaces the old priority APIs,
if you're familiar with those.
In this case, importance
is what determines
whether a notification
pops up, makes sound, is
unable to make sound, ends
up in BTW, and so forth.
You can actually
change the sound here.
You can change the
vibration, and a whole bunch
of other stuff if you're really
a superfan of notifications.
But if you're not, you may
never get this far down
into this screen.
And again, we've got another
link to your App Settings here,
and we'll put extra
stuff in the intent
so you know exactly which
channel the user was trying
to configure at that time.
And there's actually
also a little description
at the bottom.
You can set a
description to explain
what the channel is for.
I have a little bit of code
here, just a little bit.
There's much more extensive
code samples obviously
on d.Android.com, but
this is effectively
how this is going to work.
To set up your notification
channels, you create one.
The most important
thing is the channel ID,
which is the first parameter
to the constructor there.
That's just a string,
and it's totally
whatever you want it to be.
It becomes the unique
identifier for that channel when
you post a notification later.
Everything else about
the channel you set up,
it's pretty straightforward.
You give it a localized
string that the user
can understand as the title.
You give it the importance that
you would like for it to have,
you give it the sound that
you give it the vibration that
you would like for it to have,
and so on.
You set up all the initial
parameters, all the behaviors
of this channel.
And then you tell the
notification manager,
please create this.
Now, if you don't want to
track, oh, did I ever--
have I ever done this
on this device before?
Because the notification
manager of course
persists all this
information between reboots,
you can do this anytime your
app or service starts up,
and it's very cheap.
If the notification manager
sees that you already
made this channel, you can
skip-- it skips right over it.
So you can do this in
any of your setup code.
And then when you go
to post a notification,
you just throw it into
the builder constructor.
And that's it.
[APPLAUSE]
Not that's it for
the talk, we've
got more things to talk about.
Remember I said that there
was some question about what
settings go where?
So there's app settings, the
settings inside your app,
and the settings that I've now
shown you are inside Android.
Well, truth be told, there
were always two places
for notification settings.
There's always been a thing
that you can go to in settings
to control whether vibration
works, how loud things are,
and so forth.
But we've actually made a
much clearer distinction in O
about what belongs where.
In the app, we're
now letting you--
we're staying focused
on the business
rules, the what, when, why
of what kind of notifications
exist in your world, when they
get posted, what they mean.
The system doesn't
want to know that you
have a geofencing feature,
or what your social graph is.
Android doesn't
care about all that.
You define all of those rules.
The only thing that we're
moving over to Android settings
is how it behaves once it
gets on screen, or on vibrate,
or on speakers.
And that's the thing that
then the user can make
editorial control of later.
OK, there are some
questions whenever
we describe this
about, OK, well, I
don't know how to
organize my channels.
Do I have one per--
I don't know, just one?
Do I have--
OK, so here's a recommendation--
pick something that makes sense.
Pick something that is going to
make sense to your user, such
that if the user says, oh, I
kind of want this set of things
to behave differently,
that defines your channel.
So let's say that it's--
you're in some kind
of business chat app.
Maybe every room
is its own channel.
Your app might even call
them channels already.
Or perhaps a different
topic in a news app,
or a different sender, different
chat group in a messaging app.
Anything that you want the
user to tweak in isolation,
or anything that you need
to behave differently
from your other notifications,
put it in its own channel.
Because remember,
everything in a channel
behaves exactly the same way.
They all have the same
behavior so the user
can understand and control it.
We give you one additional
level of hierarchy, just
for presentation, just to make
it a little easier to organize
in the settings app.
They're called
notification groups.
I didn't show you
the code for that.
It's really easy--
just give it a title,
and assign it to each
channel as you create it.
This allows you to segment
channels as we've done here.
It's really useful for, for
example, multiple accounts.
So again, this is the
Settings app inside Android.
You can see I've got one
account, channel, channel,
channel, another account,
channel, channel, channel.
So you can control all
of that independently.
And again, the user may
never, ever see this screen.
They may just see notifications
doing exactly what they want.
But if you long-press it and
you say, oh, this is calls.
You go in here, oh,
it's called specifically
from my personal account.
Now I can make changes to that.
Many of you are already sitting
there thinking, well, OK, hmm,
I see some ways around this.
We've been thinking about
this for a little while.
Let's walk through it.
First thing is the
apps have a million
ways to be cruel to the user.
Stopping them is impossible.
What we want to do is, deal
with obvious things, right?
Because an obvious abusive
app results in uninstalls,
or it results in bad
ratings, bad reviews.
You don't want that, OK?
So now we have to worry
about the sneaky things.
And for sneaky
things, again, we want
to either prevent
them if we can,
or move them into the
obvious category, which
we know how to deal with.
So here's an example of
something that an app could do.
Oh, well, if the user
changes the channel settings,
like oh, I want to
block that channel,
or I want to put it in BTW--
well, what if I
just change it back?
And our mitigation for that
is, the API doesn't let you.
Once the user has voted,
the channel is locked.
You can't make changes to
it after you've created it.
The user has the final say in
what that channel does, period.
OK, all right, so OK, if I can't
change the channel settings,
I'm just going to
delete that channel that
has properties I don't
like, and create a new one.
OK, fine, thanks for
gaslighting the user.
So what we do in
the Settings app is,
we actually show you how many
channels the app has deleted.
We don't show you exactly what
they are for privacy reasons
so that an app can
actually clear its state
and not leak
information about you.
But you can go into
settings and see, yeah,
I feel like I've block
that five times before.
Oh yeah, sure enough,
five deleted channels.
Mm-hm, OK, now the app's
malfeasance is obvious.
OK, well, all right,
I feel like I just
want to opt out of all of this.
Can I please just make one
channel for everything?
You can do that.
And if your app only has
one thing that it does,
like it just chimes on the
hour, that probably makes sense.
But if what you're
doing is saying,
I want my critical
notifications to be
tied in fate to my
recommendations,
or my speculative
notifications, then the user's
going to have a bad
time, and you're
going to have a bad time because
all those notifications will
behave the same way, and
they'll get blocked together.
OK, wrapping up on channels.
You set up your categories.
After that, the user's in
control of how they behave.
The user happiness
should be your goal.
You work to make the user happy.
The user will get the
notifications that they want,
that you want them to see.
Everybody gets their
dopamine and serotonin
and norepinephrine,
and again I don't--
I think that's-- no, anyway.
One more thing that I want to
mention before we go-- and we
only have another
minute left, channels
are mandatory once you
target O. Specifically,
once you target API 26.
Before API 26, you can
start using these APIs
and start moving your
notifications over
to channels piecemeal.
Once you start targeting
O, any notification
you post that doesn't
have a channel
gets dropped on the floor.
I shouldn't have done
that with the clicker.
A notification gets dropped,
it never shows up for the user.
So this is definitely
something that you
have a limited amount of
time to move everything over.
Take a look at
your notifications,
organize them into channels.
You'll be amazed at how many
teams are like, you know,
I didn't even really realize
how many notifications we post.
What a great time to take stock,
and clean house, and get things
organized so that you can
go from this situation
where all the notifications are
competing for your attention
and draining your
will to live, and go
to this situation where--
there's nothing on this
slide, go to this situation
where the user sees
the ones that they
want to see in the order
they want to see them,
and is very happy and
blinky, and so forth.
Oh, one last thing--
and we've got almost no time.
We did introduce
badges on app icons.
That sort of slipped
out in the keynote,
kind of a late-breaking thing.
But we want to do
the Android thing
and make them low anxiety, give
the user control over them,
make them look nice,
and fundamentally make
them oriented around
our notification system.
So what you'll
see in the beta is
what we call notification dots.
The dot just means there are
notifications for this app.
You get to choose, as an
app, which of your channels
get dots.
So for example, a
music player wouldn't
have a dot for its
playback controls,
but it would have a dot
for its recommendations.
And users can turn those on and
off per channel, or globally
across the system as they will.
If you dismiss a notification,
the dot disappears,
so the user's in total control.
[MUSIC PLAYING]